We are now ready to discuss
the most difficult challenge in
applications of Hidden Markov Models:
how to find out the parameters of the HMM.
So far,
we have assumed that the transition and
emission probabilities
of the HMM are known.
For example, when you walked
into the crooked casino,
you knew that the dealer changes
the coins with probability 0.1,
and you also knew the biases
of both the fair and biased coins.
However, imagine that you only know that
the crooked dealer is using two coins,
and know nothing else,
know nothing about probabilities
of the biased and
fair coins, or probabilities
of changing between coins.
Suppose you observe the sequence.
How can you figure out what
are the biases of the coins, and
how often the dealer changes the coin?
Can we develop an algorithm for
parameter estimation for an arbitrary HMM?
Let's start answering this difficult
question from the unlikely scenario,
when the dealer reveals
what is the hidden path.
In this case, we will face the HMM
parameter estimation problem:
Find optimal parameters explaining
the emitted string and the hidden path.
So the hidden path and emitted string
are given at the bottom of the slide.
How would we derive transition and
emission probabilities?
In the case that the hidden path is known,
let's define T_(l,k)
as th number of transitions from state
l to state k in the hidden path pi.
For example, in this case, the number of
transitions from b to f is equal to five.
And some common sense suggests to us,
since the transition probabilities from
state l to state k can be defined as
the number of transitions from state
l to state k, divided by the number
of all transitions from state l.
And in this case it
will be five over nine.
Now, after we
estimated the probability of
transition from state l to state k,
let's now estimate the emission probability
of symbol b from state k.
And to do this,
let's define the parameter E_k(b),
the number of times symbol b is emitted
when path pi is in state k.
In our case, E_F(T) will be equal to 6,
and common sense again suggests that
you define emission probability of symbol b
from state k as the number of times
symbol b is emitted in state k,
divided by the total number of
symbols emitted in state k.
In our case, that's 6/11.
It turns out that transmission and
emission probabilities
defined in this way
define the optimal solution of
the HMM parameter estimation problem.
However, the real problem we
are trying to solve is the problem when
the dealer is not that generous,
so neither HiddenPath nor Parameters
are known, and it results in the
HMM Parameter Learning Problem,
a more difficult problem than the
HMM Parameter Estimation Problem.
In the HMM Parameter Learning Problem, we
need to estimate the parameters of an HMM
explaining an emitted string.
Only the emitted string is known.
So, let's try the following algorithm
for solving this problem.
We are only given the emitted string, but
let's start from an arbitrary
wild guess of parameters.
As soon as we guess the parameters,
we can derive the hidden path by
solving the Decoding Problem.
As soon as hidden path is known, we can
pretend that we don't know the parameters,
and we can solve the HMM Parameter Estimation
Problem, deriving a new set of parameters.
Afterwards, we can once again forget about
the hidden path we have constructed,
and use the emitted string and the new set of
parameters to derive the new hidden path.
And iterate.
This algorithm is called
Viterbi Learning for HMM.
The deficiency of Viterbi Learning is
that it is based on the Viterbi algorithm
that gives a strict yes or
no answer to the question "Was
the HMM in state k at time i,
given that it emitted string x?"
This question fails to account for how
certain we are in the yes or no answer.
And in the next section, we'll try to
design a soft answer to this question
and design a new parameter
of learning algorithm
that improves on Viterbi Learning.